but we begin this morning with rising
fears over the spread of the omicron
variant to more states across america
the strain has already been detected in
at least five states experts think the
real number is likely much higher
yesterday new york state reported at
least five cases of the variant more
than any other state so far all cases of
the strain in the u.s have been mild but
the uncertainty is taking a toll nikki
batiste is tracking the spread
the holidays are here and with them
concerns about the omicron variant as
millions of americans shop gather and
travel for the season
on thursday new york became the first
state to detect multiple omicron cases
all five in the greater new york area we
have to assume that means there's
community spread we have to assume that
means we're going to see a lot more
cases two other cases of the omicron
variant were also announced thursday
both patients reported mild symptoms one
case was a colorado woman who had
recently returned from southern africa
she was vaccinated but had not received
a booster the second case was detected
in a minnesota man who received a
booster in early november and whose only
recent travel was an anime convention in
new york city
what covett is doing is it's learning
it's adapting dr tom frieden is the
former director of the centers for
disease control he says it will take
weeks at least before we know if omicron
causes more serious illness or if it can
evade our protections for those of us
who are fully vaccinated who have had a
booster what should we do in the face of
omicron if you're older or i mean it's
oppressed or you live with someone who's
older or immunosuppressed you're going
to want to be more careful indoor spaces
i think everyone should be masked and
the more of us who make stuff the safer
all of us are
health officials are urging all of the
53 000 people who attended the anime
convention in new york city to get
tested immediately and americans who are
looking for a shot whether it's their
first or their third should visit
vaccines.gov or text their zip code to
438-829
to find a free vaccine near you michelle
important to get vaccinated all those
that we've looked at thus far with the
omicron have been vaccinated people so
nikki thank you we